yes fat six fear is six all these titles
are so goddamn confusing fast and
furious 6 there I got it again if you
have seen the trailer for this movie and
you got all these feelings and all these
expectations this movie will certainly
deliver on all of them this movie is jam
packed with action and you know what the
action is just not it's not just in your
face it's very choreographed very
stylish and they got all different kinds
of action in this movie they got macho
men kicking ass they got hot [ __ ]
kicking ass the only thing I would have
taught this movie if there were midgets
kicking ass can be imagined I just for a
second fast & furious 7 but they're all
midgets it's about family vin diesel is
the buffest jus you will ever meet and
you know what he's really cool in this
it's about family Paul Walker is blonde
and beautiful yes yeah he's okay the
rock though the rock is better in this
than in Fast Five he blends well with
the cast here's my impersonation of the
rock his eyes are there really wide
squinting Tyrese Gibson's really funny
in this him and Ludacris worked really
well together the asian guy has some
good lines in this movie he has a really
really hot girlfriend yeah I would love
to hug this woman Gina Carano is a great
addition to this cast but most
importantly there's just insane action
in this film there are so many times
where the audience will laugh because it
character looks like he's about to do
something a little bit ridiculous so
you're in that seat going no no no no
and then they do it and you're like yes
yes oh that's what I wanted orgasmic
once you're done with this movie you
want to go to your parking lot and speed
on that [ __ ] Road have cost chase you
blow up some [ __ ] this movie just get
your heart moving in the most exciting
Hollywood pure entertainment way let me
get straight to the point here all that
all I gotta say
fast and furious 6 got it super right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
show why don't you go ahead scroll to
that comment box below and tell me which
one is your favorite fast and furious
movie now that all of them are out and
if you sell the post-credit tease tell
us what do you think about the upcoming
film fast & furious 7 and if you want to
see more in-depth review of Fast &
Furious 6 go ahead and check out my show
that I do with my buddy Jerry called
reasons to see where we'll give you
reasons to see and maybe not to see Fast
& Furious 6 and last but not least if
you want to get updated every time one
of my reviews is out go ahead and
subscribe to my channel on this link
this one right here yeah just click that
button click it click it I say click
you